[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
and in case you haven't guessed it i'm
tom heap thrilled to be kicking off this
new venture the whole idea is to infect
you with my enthusiasm and excitement
for the climate change story the stakes
couldn't be higher there are twists and
turns every day heroes bad guys and
we're all involved
today's show is taking us to a couple of
dusty places the chilean desert and yes
your loft both critical in cutting
carbon i'll also be chewing the fat with
one of our experts on the fate of car
mechanics and america's climate
ambitions both looking a bit shaky but
first a quick thought about one of the
big stories of this week the climate
change committee told us that the uk
government's policies wouldn't deliver
carbon cuts required at present the two
weakest areas home energy saving and we
will be having a look at that later on
but another one was emissions from land
farming and the slow pace of tree
planting we'll save the detail on that
for a future program but a fun fact i
couldn't resist just to whet your
appetite the climate warming emissions
from degrading peak yup that's all that
marshy soily stuff
are about the same as what comes from
all our trucks chugging up and down the
road so bogs matter well to me anyway
now let's have a look at some nice clean
numbers what kept the lights on and the
cars charged this week well if you
combine the low carbon sources
renewables nuclear and biomass you get
to a healthy looking 57
well over half and that's actually about
average for the whole of last year now i
love this stuff i've even been known to
take a quick look at the national grid's
data dashboard when the wind is howling
around my house
and all this electrification is key to a
low carbon future but it will reshape
our economy and the very earth itself
and our economics editor ed conway has
been to where that's happening the
atacama desert between chile argentina
and bolivia he visited the mining region
of antofagasta home to the world's
largest reserve of lithium
the atacama desert a place of haunting
beauty of animals living in fragile
harmony with their surroundings in a
desert where it hardly ever rains
and here in its heart is the salah de
atacama a vast salt flat underneath
which are the biggest reserves of
lithium in the world
[Applause]
as we try to eliminate fossil fuels and
stem our reliance on producers like
russia we will need millions more tons
of what they are pumping and evaporating
out of this salt flat
wow it's really yellow oh it's very
yellow green and very concentrated very
if you have the chance to touch it it's
uh oily
okay
so it looks like a taste feels like oil
because it's so
and the viscosity is so high
corrado works for sqm a company pumping
and then processing this lithium into
battery materials
it's funny isn't it i think that one of
the most advanced forms of technology
these days rechargeable state-of-the-art
batteries begin their life with that
glugging noise
over there as that concentrated brine
solution is pumped through from that
pond
over to this one look you can see it
coming out there now that
is about 25
lithium chloride that is going to go
into your smartphone battery or your
electric car
a special place this place though oh
definitely yes
these are the special condition for the
solar to form
these mountains
falls volcanic rocks
water and perfect condition for
evaporations or arid places
in the arid hills and villages above the
salah where water and money are scarce
locals warn of the consequences of
lithium mining
and concerns about lithium and copper
mining chile also has the world's
biggest copper reserves have now caught
the ear of this country's new government
it wants to set up a state lithium
company and to introduce tougher rules
protecting the environment and local
communities
where those resources are transported it
is clear that alongside the mineral
riches is severe poverty
another reason why the government is
talking about doing things differently
including adopting a new constitution
for one of its authors change is needed
there have been a
decrease in flamingo population in the
in the last 10 years
a circle of 12 percent of the flaming
population have decreased it's
impossible to live without mining we
need materials of course but the scale
is huge and it's affecting a long term
oracle systems
as the world rushes towards net zero
replacing fossil fuels with wind and
solar power the demand for the minerals
they have in this country will only
intensify
[Music]
but so too will the compromises in what
is fast becoming a new age of mineral
exploitation
ed conway sky news in chile
well skies economics and data editor ed
conway joins me now ed stunning film
great story but you also covered another
critical element
copper vital to our electronics
revolution what's the story there
yeah it's incredibly important actually
i should say by the way i'm in south
wales i'm no longer in chile i'm in the
exact opposite when it comes to rainfall
uh but actually incidentally this used
to be a big area for copper smelting
here although i'm working on a different
story on uh right now you'll be able to
see that next week copper is incredibly
important it's incredible right uh
incredibly important right now for our
lives you know we use it in electrics we
use it in piping but as that green
revolution takes place the demand for it
is just going to go even higher
potentially some people estimate up to
four to nine times as much copper needed
for green energy as it is right now so a
massive increase and that's because you
know when you look at the various
different devices we're using right now
but we want to use more of them we want
to electrify the world that is the same
as eliminating our reliance on fossil
fuels so we need much more copper and
the vast majority of the world's copper
at least in terms of reserves is in
chile
now a little fact that i dug up is that
an electric car has close to my body
weight in copper inside 86 kilos why so
much
i mean it's
partly it's because of all of those
different electric contraptions that go
within the car think about a motor you
know electric motor has a lot of copper
in it just in the windings to make it go
round and then you've got all of the
different wires taking uh the charge
from the batteries through to the uh to
the motors but by the same token you
know like i say we have lots of copper
in our lives right now but we don't
really think about it much there's still
quite a lot in a normal conventional car
right now but that just goes through the
roof when it comes to electric cars we
mentioned copper in our lives right now
and a thought struck me about actually
about recycling that and i'm going to
bring something in that came from my
house here thank you very much andrew
this is a copper pipe that came uh from
my house when i took out the central
heating system now in theory a lot of
people are going to be doing this in the
next few years so can recycling our
existing copper help us in any way
yeah potentially we need to do more
recycling of copper we don't actually
recycle as much copper as we could and
as you say there's a lot of copper in
our lives that could be turned from
pipes into wires but getting there is
going to be a big job it's about
encouraging people to do more recycling
and that's something i think we could
all do a lot more of
thanks a lot ed and you can see a longer
version of ed's extraordinary film on
our website app or on youtube
we would of course need less electricity
and energy more widely if we didn't
waste so much and this week the
independent official advisors on climate
policy that's the climate change
committee said the government wasn't
doing nearly enough at the moment to
drive energy saving
20 percent of our carbon emissions come
from the building sector and the vast
majority of that from our homes they are
leaky
putting that right nationally would cost
many billions soon but save many
billions later and who is going to do
all the work
i've been to stockport
this quite obviously is a loft and it's
at the sharp end of all the talk we've
heard this week about energy saving it's
where heat vanishes through the roof
it's where your bills can also go and
the advisors to the government on
climate change well frankly they hit the
roof saying that the lack of policy over
this was a shocking gap
also with me in the lofties mark cox
he's busy laying some insulation
mark there seems to be insulation
already here so why more it's not in a
great condition so we're currently
topping up the insulation to 400
millimeters hopefully this will keep the
heat in the house the bills down and
provide a better environment
well can you give me a bit of a guided
tour of some of the other things you're
doing in here we've installed triple
glazing windows within the property
so it helps keep the heat in
we've put
external wall insulation i can't see
that well so so the insulation is behind
this rendered finish you should save 200
pounds a year on your energy bills 200
pounds a year 200
yeah just from this rear external wall
up to 200 pounds a year
for the average uk homeowner a deep
retrofit like this could cost upwards of
20 000 pounds the good news is your
bills will drop rapidly but in order to
retrofit all the uk's aging houses we're
going to need a huge skilled workforce
that simply doesn't exist at the moment
i was doing joinery plastering plumbing
a bit a little bit of everything and
they asked for me actually because i'm
quite into eco stuff
we're basically making the families pay
less once they move in if this actually
works and they get everything done by
the time scales like 2035 would be a
massive help
in order to meet the government's net
zero targets the number of qualified
retrofit builders needs to at least
double over the next five years alone
looks like the boss is here
there's an understanding that we have to
decarbonize every single building my
question is who is going to do that
we have a complete absence of skills
that has been building up over 25 years
within the construction industry
aliens company is training workers on
the job they're paid the living wage as
they train and they're all local
if you decided
okay i'm really going to invest
in this work in my home the thing you'd
want next is a person you can trust to
deliver it those are the people we don't
now have enough of training on-site has
stopped full apprentices have stopped
for at least the last 20 years
a job placement is not fully trained a
short-term
college course is not fully trained the
training needs to happen in a house
so i've worked in housing since i was 19
my first ever job and i've been here
ever since and i think the reason being
you actually make a difference to
people's lives
john is leading stockport homes retrofit
revolution they want to upgrade all 12
000 of their homes if you look at the
housing stock across this country in 20
30 40 years time the housing stock
that's here now will be there then if we
don't tackle it now we'll never get to
the targets which we need to achieve for
me it is sexy because it's really vital
that we do it now it's a challenge but
it's a challenge that the housing sector
is certainly up for
we're about to take a short break but
first the uk is one of the worst
offenders in europe for what's called
e-waste that's all the electronic
gadgets we've used and then thrown away
this is the rather shameful picture of
the discarded wires in my shed now i
have a question how many electric cables
do you think the uk is hoarding on those
shelves and in those drawers i'll have
an answer for you after the break
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show with me
tom heap and before the break i asked
how many electric cables are we hoarding
the answer 140 million and that in case
you're wondering is enough to go round
the earth
five times
now it's been a busy week in climate
news and i'm glad to say that with me
here to discuss a couple of the stories
is our science and technology editor tom
clark tom welcome now we heard a lot
from the climate change committee this
week big headlines criticizing the
government but you've spotted something
a little less well-known yeah something
that jumped out at me the the automotive
industry warning that 22 000 jobs could
be at risk across the auto sector as we
switch from internal combustion engine
cars and trucks to electric vehicles i
know it's a little bit odd electric
vehicles though contain fewer moving
parts so i read and as a result they're
easier to put together so fewer jobs
fewer jobs needed on the assembly line
and also much smaller supply chains and
there are lots and lots of jobs making
parts for cars that are powered by
combustion engines yeah we always hear
when it comes to car manufacturing it's
not just about the big brands that we
know there's a huge supply chain beneath
them and you're saying maybe fewer of
them that's it and it's a big shock for
the auto industry and the way that it's
organized not just in parts and in
manufacturing but also once a car's on
the road
well this is something i was going to
ask because i've talked to my local
garage about this you know they're quite
concerned about where the the jobs are
going to be in for the mechanics for
repair exactly where do they fit in when
cars electric motors don't break
as often and it's easily there are fewer
parts to go wrong and when they do
it's easier to switch them out so you
don't need that that same uh
scale yeah of repair we've got to be a
little bit careful as kind of painting
this as bad news obviously it could be
for the mechanics although quite a few
are retraining in in maintaining
electric cars but of course
basically none of us particularly
welcome maintenance builds when it comes
to our car do you know for consumers
this is this is it's definitely a
win-win but it's another example of how
we need to think about these these big
challenges of the transition to a green
economy now now something quite
different you actually reported on
recently a big deal happening in the usa
that's right a really significant court
case in the u.s the u.s supreme court
remember now it's top heavy with
conservative lawmakers put there by
donald trump before he left office
they've ruled in a significant court
case we've got a map here of the 18 coal
producing states in the us led by west
virginia and two coal companies they
challenge the u.s environmental
protection agency's
rights to limit carbon dioxide emissions
from power plants they said the epa is
going beyond the scope of its uh of its
powers to do that and no surprises a lot
of republican republican dominated
conservative states and the the supreme
court ruled in their favor the epa can
no longer regulate emissions so the
biden administration which has ambitious
plans to cut carbon in america has lost
one of its key policy instruments for
doing that but when it comes to america
i'm always told we must be careful about
looking at looking at everything from
washington it's often about what's
happening at the state level and quite a
few of those are quite pro climate
change action absolutely and that's a
really significant point here this is
about the federal government and federal
agencies ability to restrict that look
at this map these are the u.s states
that have their own net zero targets
most of them going for net zero by 2050
like the uk and the us so they'll have
their own rules for cutting carbon their
own plans for power plants and switching
to renewables so there will be progress
now quick burst what positive news have
you spotted this week
not a
great week i have to say for positive
news but one thing that caught my eye in
the context of that supreme court ruling
in the u.s australia which has also been
really dragging its feet on climate
they've just set a emissions trading
scheme for its industry to try and
reduce emissions there something they
abandoned a decade ago and they've also
toughened up their
commitment to cut carbon on the
international stage well the little one
i spotted was the company that does a
direct air capture that's pulling carbon
dioxide straight out of the air has got
plans for a new plant now i know it's
far from the panacea answer but you know
it's always and rather than all when it
comes to climate change solutions i
think tom clark thank you very much
indeed thanks for having me
now you'll find our content on every
platform tv digital and social media and
we've been asking you for your questions
all week so now we're going to try and
answer a few this uh instagram live for
the daily climate show bridgette asks is
wood that's biomass truly carbon neutral
and sustainable over time enough to use
in power stations well for an answer to
that who better to ask than our climate
change and energy correspondent hannah
thomas peter
biomass is considered the uk's second
largest source of renewable energy after
wind but there's a big debate over
whether it should be called renewable at
all
those who say it is points the fact that
you can regrow trees that makes it
inherently sustainable and renewable but
there are lots of critics of biomass
energy they say that when you burn wood
it releases carbon they say that
replanting schemes can take decades to
come to fruition the british government
considers biomass energy a vital part of
the energy mix and a critical part of
hitting net zero carbon emissions
targets by 2050 but it is funding a
scheme to increase production of more
sustainable biomass energies in the uk
including algae and seaweed
and scott sent in this question how does
the uk's climate strategy have a global
impact when countries like china are so
massively polluting well scott i think
we need to be a little bit careful about
always putting china in the naughty seat
here they are the huge developers of
renewables wind and solar up there in
the top countries in the world
secondly it helps to lead by example we
saw a bit of that last year with the
climate change talks in glasgow the fact
that we could at least talk a good game
here in the uk did help i think to bring
others along finally there's a sort of
moral question just because someone else
is doing something bad robbing a bank is
it right for you to do it as well
and jordan sent in this how can i know
that my financial services banks
mortgages and insurance and investing my
money ethically money not really my
field so we've asked an expert timmy
merriman johnson for an answer hi jordan
thank you very much for the question a
simple way to find out how ethical the
financial services you're using are is
to visit the ethical banks and building
society's rating table by the good
shopping guide this table lists the main
banks and building societies in the uk
giving them an ethical index score out
of 100 and a red amber or green rating
if you want to find out how ethical your
pension is assuming you're paying into a
workplace pension there's every
likelihood you're paying into a default
pension plan particularly if you've been
auto enrolled into one you can actually
change your pension from a default to an
ethical plan by logging into your
pension platform if you have the details
your hr department should be able to
help you with this
that's just a flavor of the questions
you sent in so what else do you want to
know
if you scan the qr code on your screen
right now you can send your questions
directly to us or follow us on your
favorite social media platform add your
question in the comments and we'll find
them and of course try to answer them
well that's it for this week thanks for
joining me on my first weekend show now
if you've got a spare moment before next
week's episode why not nip up in your
loft and check your lagging bye
[Music]